I've been wanting to talk about this for
a while and just haven't gotten to it
this week a few days ago we learned that
Amazon is buying grocery grocer Whole
Foods for 13.7 billion dollars this is
the biggest purchase that Amazon has
made and it will instantly make Amazon
the biggest player in the grocery
industry in the United States and it's
not really a surprising move because
Amazon's been dipping into grocery for a
while they first started with this
Amazon pantry thing then they launched
Amazon fresh which recently lost
launched here in Boston and I've
actually been using it and I really do
like it
and the drone delivery ideas that we've
heard from Amazon would also make a lot
of sense for particularly perishable
items you get them delivered quickly and
groceries would certainly fall under
that umbrella so there are some concerns
here and there are some interesting
angles to this the concerns are anytime
you see further consolidation of major
players within particular industries you
you are immediately going to think about
the consumer losing power within the the
sort of pricing model you're going to
think about Monopoly and oligopoly and I
don't want to write those off right now
I'm going to sort of get back to that
but I want to start with what this could
mean for Amazon right grocery is a
business with really thin margins Amazon
is a specialist at going for volume over
profit margin and taking market share
and that's a strategy that could do
really well for them if applied to the
grocery industry they also have made a
major real estate purchase here right
Amazon now gets really great locations
in major urban areas from which they can
sort of do anything they want whether
it's warehousing for Amazon products for
this two hour one hour delivery that
they're offering in many cities new
ventures altogether skies really the
limit and it's very interesting to me
Pat that the company known for moving
from in person to online right the
online bookseller which was so damaging
to the you know small booksellers etc
etc they are now moving back to
brick-and-mortar in many ways they're
they're doing physical Amazon bookstores
they're buying a physical grocery store
chain it's a very interesting reversal
we're seeing well I mean with many of
these industries you don't necessarily
have to see the product in person before
you purchase it but with groceries
oftentimes you want to see your produce
like is your avocado right before you
buy it that that's a concern and I think
that that's one reason why the the
physical grocery store is going to
continue being a thing for some time but
food delivery as a sort of convenient
consumer service it's clearly the
direction that Amazon is working on with
Amazon fresh and buying Whole Foods is
going to drastically help them
accelerate that and they could also look
at using Amazon Prime to connect the
whole foods maybe Amazon Prime members
of which there are millions and millions
in the United States I read that more
than half of American households with an
income over $100,000 are already
subscribers to Prime and they spend a
thousand dollars a year with it imagine
I don't know special discounts for
people at Whole Foods who have an Amazon
Prime membership or whatever the case is
so this is all very interesting but when
you get this degree of consolidation of
ownership and markets it will rarely
favor the consumer with lower prices and
Amazon is now involved in so many areas
of our lives that I have friends calling
this downright dystopian right I mean
you'll be able to use you can already
use Amazon grocery delivery to order and
make dinner which you will watch while
watching an Amazon Studio produced
original series like the man in the high
castle on the TV and sound system that
you bought from Amazon all shipped free
in two days to you because you're an
Amazon Prime member so some people very
excited by this some people very
concerned by this is it okay to be on
the fence on this one because while I'm
excited with the innovation that Amazon
can bring in revolutionising the grocery
industry yeah also the consolidation of
corporate power is really concerning and
that's a lot easier to critique when
we're talking about say the AT&T Time
Warner merger yeah as it is with this
with this I think people have more of a
first sense of how it'll be good for
them and then how it'll be bad whereas
cable companies are already so disliked
that I think when we hear about
consolidation there you first think
about the negatives and then maybe the
positives one way or another we're in
the future right I'd say not for better
or worse but as you're pointing out for
better and worse we are very very close
to a future that has been described I
guess in science fiction for a very very
long time
are we in some ways yeah I would say so
maybe tomorrow tomorrow will be in the
future but this is this this is heavily
being discussed on our reddit discussion
forum david pakman.com slash reddit talk
to us there today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30-day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s